the big China sellout that's the focus
of tonight's angle
now whether it's friendship or romance
or a strategic Alliance all
relationships start somewhere and
sometimes there's the long buildup of
anticipation so guys worry about getting
shot down and girls they wonder if he'll
ever call well Ukraine's president
zielinski finally got his call the one
he had been hoping for from president XI
so was there a spark
that seemed like it from the readout
zielinski described the hour-long call
as meaningful and a powerful impetus to
the development of our bilateral
relations
now in fact there's a follow-up date
that is already planned Chinese
leadership said today that Beijing will
send an Envoy to Ukraine to discuss a
possible political settlement settlement
to Russia's war with the country well
dialogue and negotiation
XI jinpin said are the only way forward
now had we had smart leadership in the
United States it would be the U.S
driving the parties to peace
negotiations not China
early on in this conflict the angle
warned that the longer this war dragged
on the more it played into China's hands
president XI and one called the Vladimir
Putin could end these hostilities hey
Vlad no more wheat purchases no more oil
buys tavarish until you stop the killing
how sad is it that a brutal regime like
China
will be the leader in brokering the
peace deal that we desperately need
and now that is clearly the case is it
not
well China is thinking strategically
here Michael pillsbury's book The
Hundred Year Marathon explains their
thinking quite well
she knew that to have leverage he first
needed economic power and so he pursued
a fiercely nationalistic economic policy
to do just that
then he used that leverage to advance
China's Global ambitions
China has enough money to buy off pretty
much anyone anywhere and it's doing that
in every continent including our own
in contrast look at how weak Biden's
team is
French president macron visited the
White House and he complained about the
inflation reduction act hurting European
Imports and what did Biden do he
instantly caved but when macron travels
to Beijing oh a different story he tells
G how excited France is about forging
stronger ties and he stresses that
they're not blind followers of the
United States
so a major European country sees that
China has the power China has the
momentum and Biden has none
forget acting with authority the man
can't even speak with authority
regard to uh to age you know and and
pulling that I noticed the polling dad I
keep hearing about is that I'm between
uh
42 and 46 favorable rating and making it
sound like Biden's really under what
um and number one number two when the
same polling data asks whether they
think what kind of job I've done it gets
overwhelmingly positive results
he's going to need leaders who think
beyond the immediate goals of activists
like the climate crazies that Biden is
bowing down to so the obsession right
now with electric vehicles and the
attacks on our fossil fuel industry
that's just further empowered China and
anyone who is surprised today about the
massive gains China's making in EVS
they haven't been paying any attention
a new chinese-backed battery plant in
Michigan is getting Democrat
congresswoman Debbie dingle's attention
am I worried about National Security
implications I have to tell you that I
am and I want to get it to the point
that we don't need a joint venture
within with China
well I had Biden not cave to the
greeniacs on oil and gas we wouldn't be
finding ourselves vulnerable like we are
now
but we sabotaged ourselves by voting in
Biden but Biden he's not worried
it's not about China
I'm not concerned about China remember
America invented a semiconductor we
invented it we used to have 40 of the
market
and we decided that what we're going to
do over the past
I don't know how many decades we decided
that it was going to be cheaper to
export jobs and import products
the ignorance should terrify you
so look there are three takeaways from
this past month first president XI will
be the big Victor in Ukraine
second China has more influence now in
Europe than we do and third Biden's
post-trump European charm offensive
backfired
the AP sums it up this way over the past
two decades the Chinese government has
often used its economic half to pry
France Germany and other allies away
from the U.S on issues ranging from
military security and trade to human
rights in Taiwan
and what about the trips by world
leaders paying homage to Beijing they
write they're meant to reassure ji of
respect for beijing's control over all
of Chinese territory and urge com they
also highlight the challenge the U.S
faces as it tries to build a coalition
of countries to ramp up pressure on
Beijing over its expansionist policies
build a coalition Joe Biden couldn't
build a coalition of preschoolers to
play Ring Around the Rosie it's
ridiculous
so if American voters give Joe Biden
four more years
the message to China to Europe to Big
Business will be one of total
capitulation
if we're lucky China is going to allow
us to play the role of something akin to
being like a junior partner at a law
firm but look they're going to make all
the big decisions
and let's face this Biden's own treasury
secretary Janet Yellen she's already
indicated that they're not interested in
challenging a China That's obviously on
the move
we do not seek to decouple our economy
from China's we seek a healthy economic
relationship with China a growing China
that plays by International rules is
good for the United States and the world
it's been great for all those workers in
the Rust Belt Janet thanks a lot now as
if China didn't already know that there
was a total surrender in place under
Biden I mean Biden's people won't set up
a meeting to like hash out the debt
ceiling with Kevin McCarthy but they're
begging for a return phone call from our
communist adversary
we have said over and over again that
the president intends to call President
XI I don't have a call to read out to
you at this time we'd like to see this
relationship get onto a better footing
and when it's appropriate for the two
leaders to talk then they'll happen
no they're not returning your phone call
that's the truth now look at it this way
if you can't make a movie now with China
as the bad guy
how independent as a country are we
anyway
and that won't change anytime soon if
Biden wins the second term especially
since his Finance chair is Jeffrey
katzenberg and katzenberg is in China's
back pocket
katzenberg the Democratic King maker has
an extensive history with China perhaps
most infamously when katzenberg was at
DreamWorks in 2012 the company announced
a multi-billion dollar deal with the
Chinese government to build a Production
Studio in Shanghai
and soon after that an agreement was
reached to increase the number of U.S
films that could be released in the
Chinese market every year just before
the big ceremony in LA to Ink that deal
with katzenberg then vice president Xi
Jinping got a rousing welcome to the
United States by none other than
President Obama I want to welcome vice
president XI to the Oval Office and
welcome him to the United States this is
obviously a great opportunity for us to
build on the U.S China relationship
now we're sleepwalking into a
geopolitical calamity every year we go
further into debt to defend countries in
Europe who despise us in who are openly
working with the CCP and every year we
Outsource jobs and Technology to China
and give president XI the money he needs
to build a stronger military one
certainly growing stronger than ours
we're not going to remain a superpower
or any kind of power unless we
dramatically change course and this is
not going to happen unless we get new
leaders
the GOP Presidential nomination in 2024
should go to the candidate who best
understands these facts you know has the
will and the ability to change course
and defend our interests and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else